hello everyone i'm dana perino along
with kimberly guilfoyle juan williams of
henry and greg gutfeld it's 9 o'clock
actually no it's 11 o'clock teleprompter
person in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
President Trump takes on the Taliban the
nation's 45th president addressing the
country tonight laying out his strategy
in Afghanistan where America has been
fighting for nearly 16 years the longest
military engagement in US history
the cost of the war has been high over
2000 Americans have died in the conflict
and 20,000 have been wounded and that's
to say nothing of the 700 billion
dollars charged the US taxpayer here's
what President Trump said about his plan
to finally win the war we will not talk
about numbers of troops or our plans for
further military activities conditions
on the ground not arbitrary timetables
will guide our strategy from now on
America's enemies must never know our
plans or believe they can wait us out I
will not say when we are going to attack
but attack we will we are not
nation-building again we are killing
terrorists mr. Trump also said he is
going to put far more pressure on
regional powers to help with the Afghan
effort we have been paying Pakistan
billions and billions of dollars at the
same time they are housing the very
terrorists that we are fighting but that
will have to change and that will change
immediately
no partnership can survive a country's
harboring of militants and terrorists
who target US service members and
officials India makes billions of
dollars in trade with the United States
and we want them to help us more with
Afghanistan especially in the area of
economic assistance and development the
president also offered a warning of
sorts saying his administration's
commitment to the Afghan cause was not
absolute America will work with the
Afghan government as long as we see
determination and progress however our
commitment is not unlimited and our
support is not a blank
the government of Afghanistan must carry
their share of the military political
and economic burden the American people
expect to see real reforms real progress
and real results alright so a primetime
address by the president this was a
policy that had been under discussion ed
for many months at the White House was
one of the first things the president
asked for was for a review of everything
some of it leaked out sort of in July
but as of Friday when the president made
a final decision got to say actually
there were no leaks out of that tight he
gave his speech tonight
what was the lead-up like and what do
you think of the result I saw you on
Twitter saying that you were stunned by
the lead-up not being that exciting in
terms of there was no buildup this is a
president giving his first major foreign
policy address he's talking about war
and peace and he's talking about finally
winning this war by the way yeah which
is a big deal and in fact his first
prime time address absolutely especially
on a policy issue of this gravity here's
the bottom line one word leadership he
stepped up to the plate tonight he had a
rough week last week and he said I am
going to show leadership he admitted
that basically this is a flip-flop
that's not easy for any president to do
especially this president he likes to
show that he's tough right he said again
and again before he was running and when
he was running going back to at least
2011 get out and he said if I'm elected
I'm out enough with the money enough
with the lost lives
enough with the misadventure but he said
look I got behind that desk in the Oval
Office and I was elected to make tough
decisions this is a tough decision but
he kept using the other word not just
leadership win we're going to win I
think where it got fuzzy is he's going
to have to come up with more details and
his supporters when you say that say
wait a second we don't want to tell the
Taliban how we're gonna win I get that
but you have to at least have some sort
of a blueprint about beyond yes he said
we're gonna kill terrorists everyone
wants to kill terrorists and we're going
to stop nation-building and I think
that's something people can rally around
absolutely but how you're actually going
to do that he still didn't lay out the
details however big picture here it was
a leadership moment for him he stepped
up to the plate big time
I thought one of the big news parts of
the speech that was might have seemed
subtle because he didn't dwell on it too
much with the fact that he called out
Pakistan in particular and then he
leaned towards India more so this is a
broader regional strategy that he was
trying to lay out and basically putting
Pakistan on notice if we we know what
you're doing harboring these terrorists
we're not going to accept it anymore and
they and those countries pay very close
attention to what the President of the
United States says so if Pakistan things
that the president United States has
India in its favorite column yeah that
will maybe get them to do something
about it yeah and I distant for me was
my favorite part of the speech for me
this was the headline this was the lead
because you know it's a bit it's about
time because Pakistan has been harboring
terrorists and supporting the Haqqani
network and they've been receiving
untold amounts of money and support
supposed to be coalition building to
help fight and counterterrorism measures
what have we gotten for our money what
have we gotten you know they had Osama
bin Laden living large over there we're
not honest about that but we had to take
matters into our own hands and you it
Americans are sick of it sick of their
hard-earned money going over there to a
country that is not being the right
partner in this bargain in this fight
against terror so they should be held
accountable you got to put the Spurs in
them and that's what he did tonight and
in terms of having a you know a
strategic plan I mean I trust that he's
going to listen to Matheson to to Kelly
they agreed that pressuring Pakistan is
the right way to do to squeeze them to
get more out of their effort which
really has been middling to none up to
this point and look what they liquid to
President Trump he said he was going to
do this with Isis we've already been
able to see that he's been beating them
back so I count on him to do the same
here and it is tough he did say and
basically do an about-face about
Afghanistan you know what he's listening
to the people in the theater he's
listening to the special operator
special forces they're the CIA agents
and they're telling him this is what
needs to be done and putting more troops
or making that commitment that is
leadership and that is courage and
saying you know what I didn't have the
information before I have it now and I'm
going to follow through and do the right
thing excellent cowgirl reference by the
way you like that
excellent we're told I'm a couple of
things that he's not able to spell it
directly because he Greg will say I am
NOT going to tell you exactly what we're
going to do so one of the things that we
don't know although we kind of know is
that the rules of engagement have
changed right the way that we're doing
intelligence in the region is changing
the way we're sharing it is changing and
you're kind of smiling I'm not sure why
this work and it was giving me the eye
okay well that's interesting kind of I
thought what I was going to ask you was
did President Trump just make the
decision that leaving was worse than
staying and if you're going to stay may
as well try to win it I think so I mean
he's a typical neocon globalist I kid
actually you knew this was different
how did you know this was different one
key factor he said Pakistan not apakah
Stan and when you heard that you go up
things are changing things are going
down the man command assay in Pakistan
until you knew that this wasn't the
newest normal issue this was a shift and
so now he's looking at he's looking at
like the way Pakistan is to the Taliban
is the way China is to North Korea and
so is saying okay this is your mess
buddy you got to clean it up that leads
to the next part which is the the
mission statement he finally gave a
mission statement that was localized and
specific and practical which is hey he's
telling the world we're not in - he's
acting is also telling people like Rand
Paul and he's telling a lot of people
this isn't nation-building anymore we're
just here to kill terrorists it's like a
guy who's saying look dude I'm just here
to paint the roof I'm not you know doing
any demolition this is my I'm a union
guy can only do one thing - making it
single the ribs and shingles know
something I can make the roots like a
sub country that's subcontractor we're
here to do that and the reason why this
is important - reason why is what we're
dealing with this nut this isn't like
World War two which we've finished in
under four years this is we keep talking
about length with this and it's because
this isn't really a war what it is is
dealing with something that will never
go away that is radical Islam the goal
here in Afghanistan and it elsewhere is
to prevent terror and nuclear holocaust
you prevent terror by seeking out the
terrorists
and you prevent nuclear holocaust to
make sure that the dirty bombs or any
nukes that the Pakistan has ends up in
the hands of these terrorists so the
only way you can do that is by
constantly being there I'm sorry but you
can call this a neocon fantasy but as
long as there is Islamism we're going to
have to be out there and we're gonna
have to be looking for these terrorists
and it's just something that's going to
be there that's why that's why the idea
of always bringing up 16 years in 17
years this is not dope this I'm an
adventurer initech the world has changed
our this we aren't fighting Japan we
aren't fighting a nation-state we are
fighting a loosely knit group of
factions that are all over the place
that's more 78 and keeps changing and
when it got what you think it's gonna
die it comes right back up it's an idea
isn't it interesting that in America
first president now has strung together
his bigger victories are on the world
stage standing down with North Korea I
came back and now then on the domestic
front he's struggling on taxes and
healthcare and trying to get that back
on track but on the world stage
he's showing more leadership than his
credit critics ever thought I'm one so
he talked about his the NATO partners
needing to pay more and to help more I
don't know if they gave him enough
credit for things that they have done up
to now and they have had sacrifices and
losses as well and there have been some
their husbands have helped but one thing
that was different that has been sort of
leaking out a little bit was that the
president might try to reach out to the
Taliban and go to talks with them when
he gave the final speech tonight that
was really not in there as sort of soft
pedaled so he might be a little bit more
skeptical on that because some thought
that talking to the Taliban and
signaling that was like giving a date
certain like President Obama did which
would basically just let them wait us
out well I did make my eyes flip over
when I heard him say that he would allow
the Taliban to be included in a new
government for Afghanistan we've never
said such a thing the Taliban has been
our enemy they've been killing Americans
they're part of the problem and then you
have them in cahoots with Isis the Isis
network that exists within Pakistan and
in Afghanistan but you know I think
there are a couple interesting things
here one off the top the president's
clearly trying to get away
from what happened last week in
Charlottesville he spent I would say a
quarter of the top of the speech talking
about racial healing that's her name
Laurie and that's the people but I'm
just telling you I don't think there's
any way coming away from the idea that
he is Reese till reacting to
Charlottesville and trying to move away
from it and trying to move away from it
by projecting strength as a military
leader so he's surrounded now by all the
generals the abandon is gone Steve
Bannon who opposed the idea of staying
suggested that we either outsource it
you know hire some people maybe some
private soldier type some mercenaries or
just pull out just leave because he said
there's no political payoff and with
that base that he has really his base is
in line with the President Trump who was
tweeting hey too much money too many
deaths what are we getting out of this
and I think they still have that
question because tonight you know I
didn't hear any specific number Fox News
and others are reporting it's about four
thousand nobody thinks four thousand
troops are going to make a huge
difference on the ground the second
thing is he had time he didn't say
here's here's exactly what I want to do
though this was in reaction to President
Obama having expressed a timeline but
the question then becomes so exactly
what is the US commitment how much
longer can we be there and we're not
involved a nation-building is taking a
shot at President Bush on that front
taking a shot at President Obama here
but the question comes back to okay
you're letting the generals and the
military advisers set your course well
what exactly is a victory should be that
it would be a stable Afghanistan where a
threat to the United States cannot be
generated but you might that is a great
point they trying to measure that and
Ernst it and saying to people oh well
this will be done in two years except
guts giving people false hope and he
didn't do that tonight and that's part
of leadership - I mean I think that's
really hard is it it does not be able to
define it and Kimberly there has that
point let me just say to that point
thing so what you're saying is it's
open-ended because he said this is not
open-ended this is not a blanket I just
said before that you said he's letting
the military commanders
side this stuff why is that a bad idea
because no no he's surrounded himself
with general flexibility no Kelly's
right McMaster that's been another's
know more about it than I do they know
more about than the president does know
they should be informing the president
but he needs people who will say to him
listen wait a second not only do we have
political concerns here in the United
States about the fact that we have this
longest war in US history but there are
concerns and other ways to go at this to
succeed if you like that in terms of
going at Pakistan if you breathe but if
you're bringing you're talking about the
people that he's surrounded by he's
surrounded by men who know loss these
are men who have seen people die in fact
his chief of staff suffered the greatest
loss you could possibly have he lost a
child in war so this is not about being
Hawks or doves it's not about if these
are thoughtful careful warriors who know
what it costs to look like would you
talk about it wing open-ended they I
think they're talking about it being
specific small agile and ruthless
meaning that when you have a mission
you're going to go in there and do it as
quickly as possible and get rid of them
it's not a large static army that
becomes a target it is small agile and
ruthless and brutal and we'll take it to
them as quickly as possible
they're screeching tonight the Hawks are
screeching at the White House because
when it was suggested that it just be a
counterterrorism operation they said no
we want to do more and we want to do is
to try to get the Afghan army up on its
feet so that they can fight them okay
but how are you bowling that you well
here do that I mean I do think that
there had been some ambiguity in the
previous administration and that the
Afghan government did not know and so
what the president has several audiences
all at once tonight one was the military
so important for them to hear what he
has to say there's a citizens at large
there's the enemy and then there's the
allies like NATO and then there's the
Afghan people and the Afghan government
so now they can wake up in the morning
or they probably are already wait given
the time changed because more they wake
up and they say look guys here's our
chance
he said he's with us it's not open-ended
we have got to get our act together and
Kimberly I'll give you the line yeah
Thank You Dana for trying to repeatedly
come to me god bless you wait up one
more time
Zippity challenge is really trying to
impact the psychology of the situation
in Afghanistan and really empower the
people and their military there to be
able to stand up to the Taliban stand up
to al-qaeda to know that they have the
backing unreasoned idli of the united
states
you know without question so I'm going
to trust that he's done his homework and
he's listening to people that he showed
that actually have military service and
have been in that theater and understand
yes
loss and they understand strategy and
what they need to do in that
geopolitical region so they're going to
make a very specific determination about
these troops that are there
what kind with you have Special Forces
operators their covert ops all of the
above to make sure that it's tactical
and that they have information real-time
intelligence coming from the ground let
them do their job I'm going to take him
at his word for that and baby Taliban
not Taliban Vaughn yeah and there have
been a lot of successes preventing
terrorist attacks preventing the safe
haven providing space for girls and
young children to be able to go to
school and women to be able to leave
their homes without fear ending the
Pakistan sanctuaries because the Attalla
ban always has some place some hole to
crawl back into and Pakistan has been
harboring them shame on you
go and blow up their sanctuaries